my girl Kaylee Cuoco it all started
yesterday with a slice of pink cake she
and Ozark's Tom Pelfrey are having a
baby girl and we've got new details
about Kaylee's secret pregnancy
giving in to sandwich Cravings showing
her beloved horses the baby bump and
revealing she used a stunt double to
shoot her upcoming action thriller role
play while pregnant Kaylee's been hiding
her surprise baby on the way for a while
it was love at first sight yeah the 36
year old only met Tom five months ago a
source tells E.T it's a crazy time for
them but they're truly so excited she
can't wait to become a mother their
daughter is expected next year but this
is what Kaylee told E.T about Parenthood
back in 2011. my kids if they dare to
tell me they want to be an actor it's
not happening in my future video to my
kids it's not
well the past is still haunting Brad and
Angelina as she calls him out for quote
alcoholic Behavior this is the lengthy
email Angie wrote Brad last year buried
within Court docks in her 250 million
dollar Chateau Mirabal countersuit in it
she calls the property the place that
marks the beginning of the end of our
family and a business that is centered
around alcohol Angie says Brad's Rose ad
after his alleged 2016 drunken airplane
fight left her shaken and was quote
irresponsible and not something that I
would want the children to see that's
why she claimed she wanted out of their
Winery business it's always felt like a
sanctuary for me now sober Brad just
opened a renovated space AG recording
studio at miraval the bitter X's have a
hearing next month just special to give
it new life moving on to Tom Brady is
Gisele sending him a message amid all
the rumors of divorce Let It Go Let It
Go days after visiting the spiritual
healer to clear out negative energy the
supermodel commented on life coach Jay
shetty's post you can't be in a
committed relationship with someone who
is inconsistent with you Gisele's
response a Praying Hands Emoji after the
NFL QB retired and unretired within 40
days we're told Giselle feels like
Thomas chosen his career over his family
and she is tired of it and this morning
E.T broke the news former Real
Housewives of Atlanta Star Cynthia
Bailey and sportscaster Mike Hill are
getting a divorce after two years of
marriage quote we have decided to go our
separate ways we both will always have
love for one another we remain good
friends folks still sliding in the DMs I
don't know how much I need to post
despite rumors sources tell ET nobody
cheated and the two have been busy with
work and it wasn't easy on their
relationship I already got what I need
yeah okay baby yeah I do so that's good
that's good because you know the CB hive
[Music]